well it has been a rough night we head to
the third 5 nothing Columbus with the lead
bumped into one of the Leafs not dressed
tonight to immediately said burn the tape
him ready for the game on Saturday
there's loon in behind it front scor
William neander 38 seconds in and he's got
his 14th of the year in that point streak
it's now seven here's Tois 1,1 points
centering it m backand Beauty and it's
52 boy here's Tim at the line K the fires scores
must score get score 53 it goes to Marner tried to
kick it in front KNE Lander shot rejected another
chance Matthews fir it's a one goal Game T to give
me the but at that point you're just getting it
towards the net and like he's done all season
long there number 22 on the year Riley is there
now tamarus moves to the front of the net back
behind it's a jam play for Matthews tamarus gets
it back in R scor are you watching this the game
is tied and man look at those Smiles the hats back
and forth third period this has been Breakaway
only to be denied then makes the defensive play
moving in Dan for Danforth behind the net Danforth
rinsky Johnson lurking on that left side rinsky
Johnson Danforth in Fr shot scores Ken Johnson
his first three-point game it's the game-winning
goal and his second of the night Columbus six
Toronto five yeah for the Blue Jackets they
give up five in the third but hey in overtime
it's Kent Johnson lots of excitement and Kent
Johnson sends everyone home in Toronto not happy